on this topic of uh
the effect of ai on our
on the landscape of work as one of the
people that have been speaking about it
in the public domain public discourse is
the presidential candidate andrew yang
yeah what are your thoughts about andrew
what are your thoughts about ubi that
universal basic income that he made one
of the core ideas by the way he has like
hundreds of ideas about like everything
it's
kind of it's kind of interesting yeah
but what are your thoughts about him and
what are your thoughts about ubi
let me answer you know the the um
question about his broader
you know approach first i mean i just
love that he's really
thoughtful analytical i agree with his
values
so that's awesome and and he read my
book and and mentions it sometimes it
makes me even more exciting
um and uh the thing that he really made
the centerpiece of his campaign
was ubi and i was originally kind of a
fan of it
and then as i studied it more i became
less of a fan although beginning to come
back a little bit so let me tell you a
little bit of my evolution
you know as an economist we have by
looking at the the
problem of people not having enough
income and the simplest thing is well
why we write them a check
problem solved but then i talked to my
sociologist
friends and people being and they really
convinced me that
just writing a check doesn't really get
at the core values
you know voltaire once said that work
solves three great
ills boredom vice and need
and you know you can deal with the need
thing by writing a check
but people need a sense of meaning
meaning they need something
to do and when you know say
steel workers or coal miners
lost their jobs and were just given
checks
alcoholism depression divorce
all those social indicators drug use all
went way up people just
weren't happy just sitting around
collecting a check
maybe it's part of the way they were
raised maybe it's something innate in
people that they need to feel
wanted and needed so it's not as simple
as just writing people a check you need
to also
give them a way to have a sense of
purpose
and that was important to me and the
second thing is that as i said mentioned
earlier
you know we are far from the end of work
you know i don't buy the idea that
there's just like not enough work to be
done
i see like our cities need to be cleaned
up yeah and
robots can't do most of that you know we
need to have better child care we need
better health care we need to
take care of people who are mentally ill
or older we need to prepare our roads
there's so much work that require at
least partly
maybe entirely a human component so
rather than like write all these people
off
let's find a way to repurpose them and
keep them engaged
now that said i do would like to see
more
buying power um from people who are sort
of at the bottom end of the spectrum
the economy has
been designed and evolved in a way
that's i think very unfair
to a lot of hard working people i see
super hard working people who aren't
really
seeing their wages grow over the past 20
30 years while
some other people who have been super
smart and or super lucky
have uh have had you know have made
billions
or hundreds of billions and uh i don't
think they need those hundreds of
billions to have the right incentives to
invent things i think if you
talk to almost any of them as i have you
know
they don't think that they need an extra
10 billion dollars to to do what they're
doing most of them probably would
would love to do it for only a billion
or maybe for nothing first for nothing
many of them yeah i mean you know a
a interesting point to make is is you
know like do we think that bill gates
would have founded microsoft if tax
rates were 70 percent
well we know he would have because they
were tax rates of 70
when he founded it you know so um i
don't think that's as big a deterrent
and we could provide more buying power
to people my own favorite tool is
the earned income tax credit which is
basically
a way of supplementing income of people
who have jobs and giving employers an
incentive to hire even more people
the minimum wage can discourage
employment but the earned income tax
credit
encourages employment by supplementing
uh people's wages you know
if the employer can only afford to pay
him ten dollars for a task
the rest of us pick kick in another five
or ten dollars and bring their wages up
to 15 or 20 total
and then they have more buying power
then entrepreneurs are thinking
how can we cater to them how can we make
products for them and it becomes
a self reinforcing system where people
are better off andrea and i had a good
discussion
where he uh suggested instead of a
universal basic income he would
suggested or instead of an unconditional
basic income
how about a conditional basic income
where the condition is you learn some
new skills
we need to reskill our workforce so
let's make it easier for people to
uh find ways to get those skills and get
rewarded for doing them and
that's kind of a neat idea as well
that's really interesting so i mean one
of the
questions one of the dreams of ubi is
that
you provide some little safety net
while you retrain while you learn a new
skill
yeah but like i think i guess you're
speaking to the intuition that
that doesn't always like there needs to
be some incentive to reskill
to train to learn new things i think it
helps i mean there are lots of
self-motivated people but they're also
people that you know maybe
need a little guidance or help and and
and
i think it's a really hard question for
someone who is losing a job in one area
to know
what is the new area i should be
learning skills in and we could provide
a much better set of tools and platforms
that map said okay here's a set of
skills you already have here's something
that's in demand let's create a path for
you to go from where you are to where
you know you need to be
you